Ubisoft upcoming take on the strategy
genre is a somewhat unique one called
Champions of interior the game has both
elements of turn-based city-building and
real-time MOBA combat with fights played
out by controlling three unique heroes
at once the game is medieval fantasy
themes with the usual swords magic and
castles setting the scene but anterior'
doesn't take itself too seriously the
narrator of the story is quick to make
light-hearted jokes whenever you can and
they set the game's tone even if they
are a little bit lame combat is the main
focus in interior the game's beginning
place me in control of three heroes in
an adventure gameplay mode which puts
you in an objective based fight on a
top-down map objectives go between claim
X number of outposts kill X number of
enemies and defeat boss I could move the
heroes as a group and micromanage each
of their individual skills the main
feature of anteriors combat system is
the elemental wheel which is five
elements that interact in a sort of rock
scissors paper type relationship so
water beats fire fire beats metal metal
beats nature nature beats lightning and
lightning beats water everything else in
between just as normal damage for
example metal element moves inflict 100
percent of damage to water each hero has
skills that can be cast using the qw e
or R keys and you choose which three
heroes you want to bring in to battle
with you when you're controlling all
three heroes at once coordinating
attacks requires a bit of
micromanagement but skills aren't
particularly different between heroes
thankfully and Syria lets you pause at
any time during battle and it will also
automatically pause as soon as you
triggered any fight to let you know that
you're entering combat I found that the
game's unit Pathfinder would often be a
source of frustration heroes would run
around or glitch in their movement in
strange and baffling ways like running
around in longer ways than necessary or
running into each other more than once I
had to manually redirect a units
movement to stop it riding around like a
headless chicken it's not necessary to
fight every enemy on the map and there
are times when avoiding enemies was
crucial this is because heroes didn't
have any natural health regen and you're
forced to rely on bringing potions in to
heal this is where the resource
management side of champions of
anterior' comes in and where the game
becomes turn
essentially you're given a village to
manage and defend building a village
isn't as freeform as say traditional RTS
games with anterior and said restricting
building placements to select sectors of
land certain sectors give benefits to
specific buildings that are placed on
them such as rivers granting 50% more
production to water and lightening
material more importantly building serve
as a way to get resources that assist
with your battle because I had to rely
on potions to keep my team alive during
missions I had to restock them quite
regularly so when I was managing my
village I placed a building that would
give me a water carrier who would help
keep my water supplies topped up and
also placed an alchemy building that
allowed me to brew more consumable
potions to take with me into battle
since the village screen is turn-based
the world only progressed once I clicked
the button to finish my turn this
allowed for me to take time to make
decisions regarding my village base my
base was made up of plots of land that
each contained a specific number of
sectors and when I had filled those up
with buildings I needed to claim a new
plot of land in order to expand
expanding is done in the world map which
presented me with branching options for
me to conquer Ubisoft boasts about
anteriors nonlinear path to victory with
multiple options - the end goal marked
out on this screen each plot of land was
marked out with the benefits they
carried with rewards ranging from the
allegiance of a new hero to more gold in
my time playing the beta I was reminded
a bit of Warcraft but Warcraft was
powered by a rich and deeper law heavy
story with characters who I grew to love
and actually cared about something that
anterior doesn't quite have which means
the interior has to rely on its
mechanics which aren't quite unique
enough to get excited about and not
enough to carry the game on their own
having turn-based city management was a
nice twist but I'm curious if the full
game will offer something a little more
to draw me into a fantasy world that
otherwise feels a bit tired and flat